[Music]
hi we're live at the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I'm all from Alpha on Twitter
and I'm here with my co-host hi I'm reg
- I'm a junior at the Illinois Math and
Science Academy and I'm part of the
Wolfram emerging Leaders program
we're here with 10 Bernard who was the
lead architect so so what do you do a
Wolfram what's your day today okay today
this is a question but basically we're
building machine learning functions for
the Wolfram language and so this
includes some high-level tools so these
kind of automatic machine learning
functions that can be used by everyone
and then Louisville functions so mainly
it's a numeric framework to develop and
and then we use these two applications
ourselves that we also put in a language
things to identify image to my speech
natural releasing as well and we also
try to take applications I've been done
by others and we'll put them in the
repository of neural networks so mainly
what we do okay so what are you doing at
the conference so to come France I'm
going to talk about some high-level
machine learning tools but actually how
to use them in advanced way because you
can use them in a full automatic way but
you can also tune a bunch of things and
often people don't know about it so so I
decided this year to talk about that
they know kind of lesson
how to music functions so tell me about
with you in machine learning at work
okay so yes so I mean there's a bit of
new things in the three areas that I
mentioned so on the high level tools we
worked a lot on unsupervised learning
this all started with classic supervised
learning function like how to do
classification of the regression but now
we're going more to in supervised things
like synthesizing missing values that I
mean that asset imputation and anomalies
in data and and this sort of thing that
require unsupervised learning and that's
that's one thing then we continue to
develop this neural network framework
there's a lot to do to be machine this
network this framework so so you know
still looking seeing and improving the
performance because formulas work is
very important to have the network
running on HTTP you for example have the
latest accelerating libraries sort of
things but also there's something we
couldn't do before for example training
generative adversity or network it's a
pretty popular system to to basically to
be able to generate image so this
something we can do in our you know a
framework I mean you can do you will be
able to do in version 12.1 and then in
the in the application side I think one
of the big thing I mean for images but
mostly for text I think that's where
there's the most activity right now so
function that is called text cases that
is able to be named entity recognition
but not just a few type of entities you
know not just city country
but like hundreds of types that's one
thing find excellent sir which is
something that can give a text as a
question it reads the things and try to
answer the question that's another
application understand the question
understand this text and give the answer
I mean yeah at the moment doesn't
understand the same way as we do it
doesn't work as well as you but but yeah
that's one of the application we are
currently working on as well okay so
actually okay let's start with with
unsupervised learning so this kind of
it's automatic machine learning function
and where the roots of all spawned
trainees learn distribution so this
really a functional giving and B
basically any data and he tried to to
capture the distribution of data set
that you gave so here it is an example
this is just two dimensional data okay
just to understand pairs of numbers and
then he learned the distribution and
alright that's tradition
this way and then you can do things like
random variates so this would be okay
for example if we at least do a least
lot of original data okay I could create
synthetic data so I could create 1,000
my not and do a list plot and this would
be data that are following the
distribution so you see it looks like
this one but actually been generated
here I can plot density function of the
distribution and but what's cool is
application you can do with it
one of them is synthesizing missing
values so let's say in this one X is 5.5
and I don't know why you will condition
this distribution on X 4.5 and then you
will sample from this condition
distribution and that's how you can
impute the missing values many missing
values
impute so anyway that's that's one of
the thing in high level machine learning
now we were coming back to mobile
plastic and supervised learning like
clustering because this time in a long
time ago we want to refresh that
entirely
you know well-documented method we do
automation things like that then that
was I was talking before you can you
will be able to Train generative
adversive network with the framework and
it's kind of it's very interesting
generative address your network so so
the idea is you have a network that can
generate stuff let's say images and the
way you train it is that you also train
something that can recognize I mean I
can distinguish if an email has been
generated or is real and they are
competing so if the generator you know
gets better at generating images then
the discriminator will get better at at
differentiating the real from the fake
and and then the generator uses the
discriminative to improve itself to say
can I can I find a way to fool
discriminator
and so it's kind of a and it's very
different to other machine learning or
usually minimize a loss function here
it's two things that I mean raising
their own loss function but competing
with each other so it's not there's no
loss function actually there's no global
loss function for the system so we
thought it'll be very hard to do with
our framework because it's a very
high-level thing so we have this net
trainer in a way to to end any of this
this monito that you see but you don't
control the training loop you don't say
you know you don't have a loop and you
say update this network this way then
update that Network this way you know
and then you can do none of this and so
we thought well we'll have to do
low-level to do again and actually not
so the trick is that it's still only one
network but it's actually two networks
inside and and that way so there's a
little bit of tricks such as okay that's
just this thing we are either for for
the next version of a long wait for
question one
this says that you will try to
discriminate the five times and then you
will try and generate a one time and
then you will loop and with this minimal
update you will be able to try again in
exposure and that's that's just one of
our things were playing with that the
training progress happening that's a
sample that are generated so you see
they get better and better and better
this is trying to do digit and if I stop
near the end okay this starts to look
like real digit so anyways that's
something we're excited on and maybe the
last thing I can talk about is a natural
releasing applications so there's been
kind of a small revolution in NLP this
last year with arrival of this three two
things is one is a transformer
architecture which new architecture so
you have network can be convolutional
they can be fully connected that can be
recommend this is a new architecture
that use what's called self attention
and this is very powerful for text and
when you combine that with training
let's say a long wave model so long word
below is something that is try to
predicting you know what's happening
next in a text try to predict the future
of a text based on its best
so it basically it is learning how to
write basically right and when you
combine these two things so transformer
and training this language alone huge
amount of data you obtain really good
network that can kind of understand text
and then you can use them for many other
applications and so one thing we did is
that we we added these networks in our
repository so the first one is called
but don't buy Google that's that's the
that's the beast and another one is
called
gbt - it's done by open AI this add a
lot of media around it the coverage
because it can it's the best at
generating text
so actually we can try if he wants to
starts you know I'm just gonna write
something and then the network you can
continue do you have an idea what we
should now we can be anything right I
like to eat chocolates I don't know
let's see so this is the next 100 words
that's this model generates so it
doesn't necessarily always completely
make sense you can see it's fake but
generally is was known on yeah that's
worth it fail for some reason in the
middle said I like to eat chocolate and
soup and so I can send him videos of
myself and he new guy come by a football
fan - you're practicing monkey stinko ok
let's be a guess I guess yes yes between
in this narrow domain yes I like to eat
chocolate he's probably a sort of maybe
it was a end of the end of minnows
alright
yes yes it's like text with billions of
words and I don't remember and I don't
know this particular one I forgot but
it's like you know a lot of Wikipedia a
lot of a lot of everything and then so
we use that's another one that we like
and we call it a day politically which
is nice that's that's what he generates
but before that language were aware much
worse and so one of the application we
did using this type of of model as as
pre-processing let's say it's something
to detect content in the text so that's
what I was mentioning before inerrancy
recognition but for various things so it
will recognize country recognized let's
say colors and respective divisions
quantity and many other things actually
it's like hundreds character like
Stadium can recognize I don't know field
name and then factory thrown so that's
what I was saying so you have a
paragraph so it's a small one how many
people live in Paris and then in try to
to figure out from the text whether well
the answer is
so what are the next steps auditioning
okay next steps well as the as many
although over we start to feel you know
like for example in the high level
machine learning cider you start to
complete itself like we are missing a
few things you know something to be good
on consequences to predict sequences
well to find no many consequences that
sort of things we need to finish and
polish on unsupervised learning side
maybe on the reinforcement learning
although it's not a huge application
right now sort of research about
reinforcement learning but in practice
is not something that is just so much
but nevertheless that's something we
could create a high-level function to to
learn you know so you can learn how our
robot can walk or all these sort of
things and then on the Neo network side
this you think I I wrote them down yes
okay this is this is things for neural
networks we try to work hard on having
our network be compatible with other
framework because it's open decay that
you in the organization and everybody
used I don't know tense you know pencil
flow or Python and and you want to be
able to still use the Wolfram language
and but then exports the network or
import a network you know and these are
the framework or export it to you know
so it work on a phone you know it's
ready to come ml any sort of things so
we're working out to support when I next
format which is kind of a format for
commercial networks another
works custom layer that's something we
are nothing will be able to do and only
twelve point one but in the next version
so you can write arbitrary you can
create your own layers basically so
interesting things about that remote
training also we try to make it we want
to make it very easy to be able from
your laptop - let's say lunch a machine
on AWS on Amazon right and then and then
put some data also on a machine and I
mean Amazon or something else and then
be able to launch a remote training that
we train on powerful GPUs graphic cars
rather than your laptop let's sort of
the things we're trying to achieve at
least for the new firmware
[Music]